time to work his magic at the defensive
end of the floor
corporal Wake Forest Demon Deacon head
coach Oh nice pass inside one way to go
on left hand no-look pass right inside
Jones was able to catch and finish
second New Orleans to turn over in the
first exhibition game hits his first
three-pointer 229 Trey's back in go to
work
oh it scores it Trey
boy he is slippery third year man from
Villanova John Collins John three field
goals all have been dumped Trey one
hands it Hunter yes he is dialed in
that's his second three he sidesteps
lays it now watch this move around JJ
right through the wicked season he's
been very impressive he averaged over 24
points a game that's a several legged
Vegas floats at home
[Applause]
sidestep three pinko the early advantage
here at State Farm arena Trey young Joey
what the other one that buries the three
these days teams play four five
preseason games you only got three weeks
but you know what it did for us it's
been free of jam take a look at this out
of Bounce play Trey lobbing it right up
there for peppery beautiful Ross hunt is
back and Ben we got behind them and that
was it there didn't no way was that this
crop the corner great quarter
little that big quarter that's just a
beautiful passed in attracted to reach
our defense has been pretty impressive
yes praise done a nice job his floater
is good swing he's got that shot down
nine surprised
[Music]
tray y'all going to work said market
drops it in by tray young there comes
behind the back awesome or that's just
beautiful fans lost it going up so you
know I made the shot so you get your
assist tray get some confidence everyday
and he shot that three-pointer with a
lot of confidence with I mean a
good-looking stroke play out for a young
waits sees his man coming off the screen
by Fernando one thing Ross would do he
would took temporary on the handoff Trey
as the head coach last year just the
second time he's had a losing record
with Eric at the helm
there's the floater from Trey young to
start think Senate eighteen his last
game the reason for that this kid finds
his spot the floater from Trey young on
the ninth quick points himself but look
at this nice little floater over the top
he is five four five and four of them
from downtown drink it's one off that's
good and a foul on Ricky Winslow two on
the shot clock both the classic good an
impossible angle for Trey young and he
got it to go
flop John them down he say he got to
create something nice little tricky
dribble takes the bump off the glass and
there it's always wanted to know what if
do you like to be six seven to twenty
five in a national champion great final
five seconds to the corner shot clock
turned off young inside able to finish
on the reverse angle checkout on the
weak side
Oh perfect feed young his vision and the
touch on the passing I mean all john
collins has to do
11 points four assists for Trey young
the lead and the finish from Turner
let's go back to Trey this is just one
on one beats it gets a second defender
committed and then just look at that
Trey young was trying to point that out
to Bembry as he slowly got into the set
Collins puts it in with a point a
differential game in chocolate
Darren unable to finish five seconds to
operate young with a chance to launch he
do what I do best don't work up my
backside I'm on the other end but this
is what makes me special I'm at Madison
Square Garden the most famous arena in
the world I've got plenty of joy
crazy crazy young widel that's good
memory
the number of deep three to get the ball
down Phoebe well he put some pressure be
defensive
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with Bleacher Report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content